Southern Alberta the land of
cattle
Cowboys wheat fields and oil
pumps but there are new additions to
this
landscape solar panels and wind
turbines we're blessed with some of the
best solar Resorts we love the Sun but
despite the sunny Prairie Skies a cloud
has been cast Over The Province and sent
a chill thr multi-billion dollar
industry just finding its
footing we got a closeup look at energy
giant ato's most recent solar farm in
Calgary welcome to Deerfoot Heather PP
hard hat vest glasses we'll get all
geared up and we'll get
out ready go y ready right let's
go the Deerfoot solar project and its
neighboring sister site Barlo together
are Western Canada's largest urban solar
farm Darcy fedchuk is the man in charge
of ato's renewable energy portfolio
which has been rapidly expanding in the
last few years the two properties
combined have enough energy to provide
electricity about 18,000 homes they'll
remove about 70,000 tons of carbon from
the grid we're really proud of them the
Deerfoot site will be electrified at the
end of November and will generate
electricity even when the snow
falls the panels are deemed bifacial so
which means on the front of them they'll
produce energy and on the back side
they'll also produce energy basically
from the Sun reflection off the ground
right Atco has long been synonymous with
natural gas in Alberta Darcy says the
company is not planning to get out of
that business anytime soon but rather
saw an opportunity in
2015 when Rachel notley's government
announced its intention to have a
Greener grid our goal is to become one
of the world's most Progressive and
forward-looking energy producers they
had instated a Target to reach 30%
renewable energy by 2030 and instructed
the Alberta electricity system operator
to come up with a plan or program to
kind of launch us towards that Target
especially if you're talking Sarah
Hastings Simon is an energy transition
researcher at the University of
Calgary Alberta solution she says was
the creation of a unique wholesale
energy Market unlike any other in the
country rather than being controlled by
a crown Corporation or by a single
government entity companies can come in
and basically develop projects and sell
the electricity from those projects into
the market and so what we saw was that
we had projects that were able to move
forward really in a big way before we
saw that in other parts of
Canada and as the cost to produce wind
and solar fell investment
boomed nearly $5 billion has been
injected into Alberta's renewable energy
sector since
2019 it really put Alberta on the map
the Open Market has attracted companies
with Net Zero goals of their own the
solar power produced by Atco here goes
into Alberta's grid but it's purchased
by Microsoft and in addition to that
they take the renewable energy
certificate that then they use to offset
their carbon intensity for their entire
Global
footprint these agreements and
government contracts have fueled a wind
and solar Gold Rush since 2018 Alberta's
renewable energy capacity has
doubled but for Alberta's current
Premier Danielle Smith the pace of
development is too fast if we're going
to bring on solar and wind we have to do
it responsibly Alberta's provincial
government hit the break suddenly in
August with an announcement that no new
renewable energy projects would be
approved for the next 6 months I don't
think that there's another example from
Alberta's history of a time when anybody
said well we're just going to stop and
not allow any new projects to go forward
during this
period the decision blindsided the
industry but was welcomed by Paul
McLaughlin he advocates for the
province's 69 rural counties we are
getting calls like crazy that people are
concerned about agricultural
productivity and food security related
to Renewables energy developers enter
into contracts directly with private
land owners so municipalities have
little say in where these large wind and
solar Farms end up and often they're in
rural areas we don't have as much land
that's aable as you think people that
need to understand that pulling aable
land out of production should be not to
say you should never do it but you
should do it with discretion and with a
vision and a plan for the
future here's the thing Paul is actually
a fan of Renewables even wrote his
thesis on them solar and wind help power
his small farm in pinoca County 95 km
south of
Edmonton but I guess what you're saying
is you'd much rather see every Farmhouse
has something like this yes as opposed
to a big sort of field full of solar
panels covering covering Farmland I
think is antithetical to the concept
but not all renewable projects are on
profitable crop land ato's Calgary solar
project sits on land contaminated by a
former fertilizer plant we're utilizing
a set of Brownfield lands that otherwise
could never be used for anything else
these large renewable projects do more
than just produce green energy they also
bring new tax dollars to rural
municipalities it's a game changer it's
changing the profile of many of the
municipalities that relied on oil and
gas so my members are extremely
favorable on Renewables they want
balance though and what they haven't
been seeing is
balance the pause on new solar and wind
projects isn't just about giving
municipalities The Voice the premier
says it's also about ensuring grid
stability if wind only works 33% of the
time and solar only works 13% of the
time we need to bring on more base load
power to make sure that we don't have
rolling blackouts that that is the
bottom line This future worst case
scenario is part of Smith's campaign
against the federal government's new
emission reduction plans which includes
weaning electricity grids off fossil
fuels by
2035 right now Alberta relies on natural
gas to meet its Bas load and Peak
demands an industry Smith fears could be
left behind certainly the more
Renewables that you have in the province
of Alberta the less natural gas that
you'll need for electricity here but
again doesn't touch on the export piece
at all which is a significant part of
our
Market even though the pause is
temporary one estimate found the
province stands to lose more than $33
billion worth of investment and 24,000
jobs I think the big concern is that
this moratorium and and in particular
the sort of dramatic action really
introduces a lot of future
uncertainty that has already LED major
energy developers to take their dollars
Elsewhere One company Blue Earth
Renewables had planned to more than
double its investment in solar and wind
in Alberta adding an additional 400
megaw but now it's looking to the Us and
other provinces Atco is too we have an
interest in Saskatchewan we're looking
at early development opportunities there
it's a sign the industry will continue
to move forward even if the Winds of
Change in Alberta mean companies will
seek sunnier Skies eyes
elsewhere